et anthony de nous aider dans cette
maison de porchefontaine c'est l'heure
du repas anthony louis et françois sont
en colocation
rien d'anormal pour ces jeunes âgés de
19 à 26 ans les une particularité ils
sont atteints de trisomie 21
cette maison jean paul ii est un lieu de
vie où sept garçons font pas et à vivre
en colocation dans un esprit familial
c'est à dire qu'ils ont chacun leur
chambre c'est leur propriété privée
entre guillemets y seller chez eux mais
il y à un lieu commun une idée née pour
accompagner ces jeunes vers l'autonomie
à travers des gestes simples comme
mettre la table parmi les acteurs la
fondation pour le logement social qui à
acheter et aménager la maison la fls
investi plus d'un million d'euros
[Musique]
neil somme l'association immobilière et
nous mettons à disposition ses biens
immobiliers et donc nous les mettons pas
à la disposition des handicapés humaine
mais alors la disposition d'une
association qui gère familialement ces
handicapés c'est la raison pour laquelle
si vous voulez les loyers qui sont
pratiqués sont des loyers du marché dans
le cadre du logement social
chaque famille verser 950 euros de loyer
de salariés des maîtresses de maison
aide à la gestion des activités des
sorties sont organisées quotidiennement
c'est la première maison de vielles deux
partagent en france